schönen guten Abend Herr Rams
guten Abend Herr Wehrmann ja schön dass
Sie wieder bei uns sind Herr Rams sollte
prigosch in seine Drohung wahr machen
und tatsächlich am 10 Mai seine
Söldnertruppen aus bachmut abziehen
welche militärischen Folgen hätte das
und zunächst mal die Aussage er hat sich
aber als vier oder fünf mal geäußert
gegenüber der Militärführung in Russland
und hat seinen Missfallen zum Ausdruck
gebracht es ist jetzt das erste Mal dass
er diesen Rückzug terminiert hat auf den
10 Mai und man darf nicht vergessen dass
sowohl die Einnahme von Wulle da als
auch die Einnahme oder jetzt die
weitgehende Einnahme von bachmut
überwiegend einen eine Leistung oder ein
Verdienst seiner Söldnertruppe ist und
nicht der regulären russischen
Streitkräfte das heißt wenn er sich dort
zurückzieht ist bachmut vermutlich in
relativ kurzer Zeit wieder komplett in
den Händen der Ukraine darauf werden wir
gleich noch ein Gedanke für diese erste
Antwort wie immer die Aufforderung an
euch uns eure Fragen und Kommentare zu
schicken über Social Media oder per Mail
heraus der Kampf um bachmut dauert
bereits seit Anfang August welche
Bedeutung hat dieser Ort eigentlich ist
sie mehr militärisch oder inzwischen
eher symbolisch
also zu Anfang war es eine strategische
Bedeutung weil die Ukrainer diesen Ort
und vor allen Dingen auch die Wege in
diesen Ort von Nordwesten bzw Westen
benötigten um auch Nachschub in diesen
Raum zu bringen für die ukrainischen
Truppen
das ist glaube ich jetzt nicht mehr so
ausschlaggebend so dass ich davon
ausgehe dass es im Augenblick um die
moralische und psychologische Wirkung
geht diesen Ort weiter zu verteidigen
wenn auch Teile bereits eine Truppe
entsprechende erobert worden sind da
geht es um die Moral der Soldaten aber
auch die das entsprechende Signal an die
ukrainische Bevölkerung die Ukraine
übrigens sieht keine Anzeichen für einen
baldigen wagnerabzug aus bachmut und
auch nicht für einen akuten
Munitionsmangel sie sehen in der
frigoschen Ankündigung lediglich den
Versuch vom eigenen Versagen abzulenken
da das Ziel bachmut bis zum 9 mai zu
erobern außer Reichweite gerate was
sagen sie dazu
wurde ja 9 mai ist in Russland ein
wichtiger Tag obwohl mittlerweile schon
viele russische Städten die sogenannten
siegesparaden abgesagt haben von daher
spielt der 9 mai sagt dass man in der
Wahrnehmung der Russen eine relativ
große Bedeutung vor allen Dingen auch
der Regierung eine große Bedeutung von
daher ist es nicht auszuschließen dass
auf diese Art und Weise Druck ausüben
will auf der anderen Seite kann er als
Kommandeur der Gruppe Wagner nicht
hinnehmen dass er ständig in diesem Ort
riesengroße Verluste hat die ja von den
Amerikanern insgesamt eingeschätzt
werden mit nahezu 20.000 Soldaten und
seine Verluste oder die Verluste werden
überwiegend von der Gruppe Wagner
getragen wir haben gerade über Russland
Durchhaltefähigkeit gesprochen wie
schätzen sie denn die Kräfteverhältnisse
ein kann der Kreml einen womöglich noch
Jahre lang dauernden kriegt tatsächlich
führen
also wenn der Kreml seine Wirtschaft
umstellt auf Kriegswirtschaft hat er
sicherlich genügend Kapazitäten auch im
sibirischen Raum um die entsprechende
Mengen an Munition auch neue Waffen und
dergleichen zu produzieren aber das
scheint bisher noch nicht erfolgt zu
sein wenn man Zahlen nimmt über den
Munitionsverbrauch etwas aus dem letzten
Jahr August September und die mit den
heutigen vergleicht dann ist sage ich
mal der Verbraucher Munition gerade
hatte Munition bei der russischen Seite
doch deutlich gesunken das heißt die
Vorräte dort sind nicht unerschöpflicht
und bei Großgeräten stellt man fest dass
immer mehr
ältere Panzertypen auf dem Gefechtsfeld
auftauchen und von daher da
offensichtlich auch die Reserven nicht
so groß sind wie sie möglicherweise von
anderen Leuten entsprechend eingeschätzt
worden sind aber mit Blick auf die
Situation Ukraine Russland im Vergleich
hat Russland sicherlich das größere
Stehvermögen und das Stehvermögen der
Ukraine muss gewährleistet werden durch
die entsprechende Versorgung mit
Munition mit Großgerät mit Waffen vom
Besten her
ja ähm wir haben einen Kommentar
anonymer Weise die oder besser
eigentlich eine Frage ist bachmut nicht
unwichtig wenn die Ukraine an anderer
Stelle die Front durchbricht also noch
mal die Bedeutung nach bachmut ist das
denn jetzt nicht vielleicht sozusagen
der Fokus auf einen Ort gelegt wenn
gleich sozusagen auch an anderer Stelle
ja auch gekämpft wird
also ich hatte ja vorhin bereits gesagt
dass neben der ursprünglichen
strategischen Bedeutung bachmut jetzt
zur Zeit eine moralische und für die
Kampfhandlung ich sag mal psychisch
wichtige Bedeutung hat bei der Aussage
bleibe ich ich kann im Augenblick noch
nicht erkennen ob ein möglicher Angriff
der Ukrainer die bekannte Gegenoffensive
möglicherweise in eine andere Richtung
zielt das könnte beispielsweise runter
nach Süden sein richtigen molito Paul
also in der Oblast saporisia von daher
wäre das eine weitere Variante wenn aber
die Ukraine dort tatsächlich in diesen
Raum angreifen sollte dann würde das
bedeuten dass auch von der russischen
Seite her Kräfte umgruppiert werden
müssen und damit möglicherweise auch der
Raum bachmut nicht mehr so nachhaltig
angegangen werden kann wie das in den
letzten fünf oder sechs Monaten passiert
ist da kann ich gerade ein Haken denn
heute Nachmittag gab es diese Meldung
russland hat also die Teile Evakuierung
von Gebieten nahe der Südfront in der
Ukraine angeordnet Familien mit Kindern
und älteren Menschen sollten
vorübergehend wie Sie es aus den von
Russland gehaltenen Front Gebieten in
der Region saporisch ja diese gerade
genannt haben gebracht werden weil der
Beschuss von ukrainischer Seite
zugenommen habe 18 Dörfer und Städte
sein von der Maßnahme betroffen dass
erinnert ja ein wenig an das russische
Vorgehen in Hassan letztes Jahr im
November auch da gab es damals einen
Rückzug der allerdings dann auch in
politisch in Russland stark kritisiert
wurde aber auch diese Meldung jetzt
scheint ja die Zweifel an Russland
Stärke im Süden zumindest zu bestätigen
also ich möchte darauf hinweisen dass
die Ukrainer ja damals im Raum chersong
sehr erfolgreich mit weitreichender
Artillerie gewirkt haben und auf diese
Art und Weise auch einen Großteil des
Nachschubs der Russen abgeschnitten
haben so dass die Russen im Prinzip dann
das nördliche
Opfer räumen mussten eine ähnliche
Situation allerdings nicht vom Gelände
ja so vorteilhaft könnte sich mit Blick
auf minitopol und Richtung Süden
ebenfalls entwickeln und offensichtlich
nehmen die Ukrainer jetzt wieder tiefer
liegende Bereiche von den Grenzlinien
aus in unter Feuer einfach auch wieder
um den gleichen Effekt zu erzielen
nämlich die vorne eingesetzten
russischen Truppen von Nachschub und
Versorgung abzuschneiden dafür sprechen
auch die beiden Unglücke mit den Zügen
wo die Gleise gesprengt worden sind
dafür sprechen auch die Angriffe auf die
treibstofflage die stattgefunden haben
von daher dürfte die Methodik und die
Art des Angriffs die Angriff
Vorbereitung wenn ich das mal so sagen
darf
von Seiten der Ukrainer dem ähneln was
damals in der Oblast Personen gemacht
worden ist das geht jetzt schon in den
Bereich früher als Offensive kommen wir
gleich auch noch mal kurz darauf zu
sprechen vorher noch die Frage von
Matthias Koch an sie kann es sein dass
Putin viele Ressourcen für die Creme
zurückhält für die Creme wohlgemerkt und
diese nicht unnötig für bachmut oder den
Don Bass zu opfern
das ist durchaus möglich die Krim spielt
für Putin eine symbolische Rolle ein
symbolisch wichtige Rolle was in
gewisser Weise auch nachvollziehbar ist
die an Lektion damals der Krim wurde ja
durch Russland mit den berühmten kleinen
grünen Männchen Betrieben seitdem
befindet sich die Krim im Besitz von
Russland er hat die Brücke von kerscht
die ja teilweise wieder zerstört worden
ist bauen lassen oder auf diese Art und
Weise die Versorgung der Krim
sicherzustellen von daher spielt das
sicherlich auch für Putin auch für
Russland eine symbolische Rolle die Krim
zu halten und da möglicherweise auch
zusätzliche Kräfte zusammenzuziehen aber
ich muss in dem Zusammenhang dann darauf
hinweisen dass wenn die Landbrücke zur
Krim tatsächlich verloren gehen sollte
ist für die Russen schwierig wird auch
über das Schwarze Meer mehr mit
entsprechender seeversorgung und
dergleichen mehr die Truppen dort
entsprechend zu versorgen so dass sie in
der Lage sind auch über einen längeren
Zeitraum Kampfhandlungen zu
durchzuhalten das gleich dann so ein
bisschen der Situation an der in der
Oblast Person und das könnte dann eine
ähnliche Entwicklung nehmen dann
interessanter Aspekt sie hatten vorhin
schon angesprochen es wird viel über die
ja wahrscheinlich bevorstehende ich
nenne es mal so früher als Offensive der
Ukraine spekuliert oder hat die in ihren
Augen schon begonnen es gab ja sie haben
es angesprochen schon Drohnenangriffe
offenbar auf Treibstofflager und auch
andere Infrastruktur also ist die schon
im Gange
also ich würde das bestenfalls als
Vorbereitung für diese gegen Offensive
wurde für die Offensive sehen die
offensivart in meinen Augen noch nicht
begonnen aber ich ziehe auch da noch mal
eine parallele einmal Richtung chakif im
vergangenen Jahr und Richtung Personen
vergangenen Jahr in beiden Bereichen ist
lange über die gegen Offensive der
Ukrainer gesprochen worden bevor sie
dann tatsächlich mit entsprechenden
Gelände gewinnen sowohl oben im
Nordosten als auch unten im Süden
wirklich Raum gegriffen hat und dann den
Ukrainern tatsächlich Erfolge gelungen
sind die dann auch für uns alle sichtbar
auf der Karte gewesen sind das ist
einfach eine ganz einfache Tatsache und
eine Entwicklung könnte wenn der Angriff
das tatsächlich nach Süden mit
Schwerpunkt geführt wird könnte sich
dort auch in gleiche Art und Weise
ergeben also jetzt hatten sie schon
gesagt wo in etwa die ukrainische
Offensive sein könnte hat denn die
Ukraine dafür inzwischen auch genug
schwere Waffen auch genug ausgebildete
Truppen ist sie also militärisch in der
Lage diese Offensive auszuführen
also die Zahlen sind die Tage genannt
worden vom Nato-Generalsekretär der von
230 Kampfpanzern und von weiteren 1.550
gepanzerten Fahrzeugen sprach die im
Prinzip aus dem Westen geliefert worden
sind die Ausbildung der Soldaten für die
bisher gelieferten
Kampffahrzeuge Kampfpanzer und Fahrzeuge
ist abgeschlossen wobei man die Zahl
1550 bitte nicht überbewerten sollte
denn dabei handelt es sich um alle Arten
von gepanzerten Fahrzeugen wie
Schützenpanzer
Panzer die dazu dienen Material oder
Personal zu transportieren das heißt das
sind nur relativ wenige Kampffahrzeuge
dabei die ich mal neben den 230
Kampfpanzern in der Größenordnung
vielleicht von 4 bis 500 einordnen
verstehe
eine Frage erreicht uns von QR DNK
interessanter Name sollten die sollten
er fragt noch mal nach Mut wirklich
abziehen wie wahrscheinlich wird dann
die militärische Eskalation also er
meinte mit Schwere der Waffen auch durch
die russische Regierung selbst denn die
würde ja voraussichtlich an die Stelle
der Wagner treten
also man müsste wenn die Wagner syltner
abziehen müsste man diese ersetzen
entweder durch ein anderes ziviles
hilfskurs gibt ja noch eins Patriot
heißt das wird von der Firma Gazprom
finanziert die dort auch jetzt bereits
zum Flankenschutz der Wagner sollten
eingesetzt sind ähnlich wie auch
russische reguläre Streitkräfte bis hin
zu Luftlandetruppen für diesen Schutz
dort sich befinden aber es würde
bedeuten dass die wagnergruppe im
Prinzip durch reguläre Streitkräfte
ersetzt werden müsste und das würde
möglicherweise die Fähigkeiten der
Russen in diesem Bereich durchaus
überschreiten dass die eine Anmerkung
und die zweite die ich dazu habe wir
alle wissen noch aus der aus dem
vergangenen Sommer das um oder Herbst
das obwohl sie da gekämpft worden ist
mit einer ähnlichen langen nicht so
lange wie bachmut dauert aber auch
bachmut jetzt mit seinen fünf bis sechs
Monaten ist ja nun auch eine sehr lange
Kampfhandlung und eine sehr intensive
Kampfhandlung und man muss schlicht und
einfach feststellen dass offensichtlich
die regulieren Truppen die Erfolge die
die die
Gruppe Wagner zum Teil auf
menschenverachtende Art und Weise
erzählt hat bisher nicht hat realisieren
können aber sie würden schon sagen dass
da Erfolge waren von Seiten der
wagnertruppe weil das auch eine Frage
ist immer wieder an uns hier im Chat
herangetragen wird haben die denn
überhaupt so eine Rolle gespielt
tatsächlich für Russland wie würden sie
das beantworten
also ich sehe das so dass wolle da nicht
in die Hände der Russen gefallen wäre
wenn die Gruppe Wagner nicht gewesen
wäre und die Gruppe Wagner ist auch
jetzt in bachmut der hauptgefechtsträger
da gibt es überhaupt keine Zweifel dran
verstehe so dann vielleicht noch mal
jetzt haben wir überwachen und länger
gesprochen noch mal allgemein wir waren
vorhin schon beim Thema gegen Offensive
der Ukraine und wie die und wo die zu
erwarten sein könnte reden wir
vielleicht noch mal über Russland in
diesem Zusammenhang denn wie würde denn
Russland auf eine ukrainische Offensive
reagieren bleibt Putins Truppen nur die
Möglichkeit mögliche Vorstöße abzuwehren
oder sehen sie eher die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass Russland
seinerseits noch mal irgendwie proaktiv
sozusagen wird
also wir müssen uns zur Beantwortung
dieser Frage die lange Front angucken
die ja unten vom denn jepper im Süden
bis rauf nach reicht und wo
strategischer Vorteil die Ukraine die
innere Linie besetzt und damit auch
Truppen schneller verschieben kann als
es die Russen auf ihrer Seite auf der
äußeren Linie können das ist einmal ein
ganz wesentlicher Punkt
ich gehe davon aus dass die Ukraine mit
sehr sorgfältige Aufklärung festgestellt
hat wo mögliche Schwächen der russischen
Seite liegen und ich denke dass sie
aufgrund dessen was sie im letzten Jahr
gezeigt haben auch versuchen werden an
den Schwachstellen der Russen
anzugreifen wenn das so ist dann
bedeutet das dass die Russen aus anderen
Bereichen Truppen abziehen müssen oder
Truppen aus Russland nachfüllen müssen
um dann dort diese Bereiche entsprechend
wieder zu verstärken und dann
tatsächlich einen ich sag das mal gegen
Gewicht zu der gegen Offensive der
Ukraine bilden können wobei ich beides
nicht überschätzen würde dafür fehlt der
Ukraine hinreichend Material und auch
zum Teil Munition wir haben ja die
Diskussion über munitionslieferung bis
in die Europäische Union hinein und wie
man die Ukraine besser unterstützen kann
von daher die Ukraine schöpft dort auch
nicht aus dem Vollen weder bei Personal
noch bei Material noch bei
Kampffahrzeugen und Munition von daher
muss die Ukraine mit ihren Kräften sehr
sorgfältig umgehen und muss sehr
sorgfältig darauf achten wo sie die
Angriffe ansetzt damit Sie auch
tatsächlich die Schwachstellen der
Russen treffen wir kommen langsam zum
Ende haben aber noch mal eine Nachfrage
bezüglich der Krim von Ismael 04 Herr
General der ehemalige Oberbefehlshaber
der US-Armee in Europa ben hat es sagt
dass die Ukraine die Krim bis zum Sommer
befreien könnte wie sehen Sie das
also ich kenne Ben Hodges sehr gut ich
weiß nicht ob er sich neuerdings eine
Glaskugel gekauft hatten ich bin mit
solchen Vorhersagen ausgesprochen
vorsichtig ich habe bei einer Sendung
von ihnen vor ich sag mal einen guten
Dreivierteljahr mal gesagt ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir den 24 August den
Nationalfeiertag der Ukraine unter
anderem Vorbedingungen dann feiern
können und begehen können ich bin
vorsichtig ich möchte da keine
Zeitlinien nennen egal ob wir über den
Angriff der von chakiff aus nach Osten
und Südosten vorgetragen worden ist oder
den Angriff der auf Person oder in
Person geführt worden ist in der Oblast
und für die nehmen das hat alles seine
Zeit gekostet von daher sollten wir mit
solchen Prognosen oder solche
Vorhersagen vorsichtig sein um auch um
bei unseren zuhören und Zuschauern
keinen falschen Eindruck zu erwecken auf
der anderen Seite muss ich bin hübsches
recht geben es wäre gut wenn die Ukraine
gute Fortschritte machen würde weil ich
befürchte das auch bei uns in Europa bei
den westlichen Staaten irgendwann die
Geduld was diesen Krieg angeht
Inger werden wird und das ist der
schlechteste was passieren kann denn die
Ukraine braucht unsere Unterstützung
dann nehmen wir das als Schlusswort der
ehemalige Nato-General Egon haben zwar
das von uns äh für uns ganz herzlichen
Dank für das Gespräch heranz und Ihnen
einen schönen Abend danke sehr